こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん趣味はありますか僕の趣味といったら基本的に
インドアでは基本的に重要連れてゲームするくらいしかないんですけどもうちょっと
こうあなたの趣味を見つけようってわけでもないんですけどもあの
ゴルフちょっとゴルフやってみたいなと思っちゃってまず頃減って何がいいかっていう
とあのボールどっ
名前が出てこなきゃねあとポルノ8スイングクラブなんだっけ
ゴルフクラブだそそうですゴルフから買おうと思いましてねすごいよかったんで買って
みましたじゃあ今中に入ってるんですが開けてみましょう
ゴルフ比べて皆さんとも堅いイメージがあると思うんですよ金属ボディフォルムの
ボール ok かっ飛ばしてウットパーフェクトいうイメージがあると思うんですけど
も私が見つけたらただのゴルフクラブでございますね今回買ったのはこちら
お前を大
はいこちら swing ドクターというゴルフクラブですこれ買って持ったんです
けど
ゴルフクラブって高いですねなかなかたかったですけどもいいね
あえてこれなんですけども普通のグループが2何が違うでしょうか分なんですけどパッ
と見てはわからないと思うんですよ6羽とは言われないとわからないしみたい的にも
特に何の変哲もない感じで見ると思いますがこの
ゴルフクラブ何が凄いって言いますといきましょういきますよ
なんと死ぬんで動くないこれ市鳴子
これでしなる家具ああぽるふぇの言葉わかんないんですけどこれだったしなるゴルフ
クラブらしくて頭に来いって言うじゃない使う
実に言うと
は相撲いやーもし何かたこれ雨天のかしない方がもう前上じゃねーぞこれ本当に黒で
これもベッキーのかってくらいになってるんですけどもこれ amazon で買った
時に帰ってあったんですよ
ムチのようにしなるらしいですよねこれはもうねあのゴルフクラブのように見えても
無知です
左肩はほんと事務所じゃねこれさえ使えれなと思いましてみなさんの想像している
ゴルフから固くてこのね来ます
すぐな金属音だカーって映ったと思うんですけどもこれも知られますから
そうそうおごる変えると打つようにしなく売ってるんですかね心も完全に鞭鞭鞭鞭の
吉田ってくそだ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
失って座っって
バッハんっ
[音楽]
ん
こんなやつじゃなかった上にずっとは終わって4つじゃないじゃんもう目ちってもっと
大
してるのは9本と屋根鬱じゃないじゃんほんとこっからですよ
そんなこっからもっとしたいと伺ったんですよね本当はぼくブチギレてめちゃくちゃ方
がゴルフクラブの力でこれねじ曲げてみんなが落ち着つくと取ろうと思ったんですけど
先にゴルフクラブ気を付けついてしまいました
まあ
こういう子も ends 2メジャ